I'm going to teach you sales in 60
seconds by giving you seven secrets that
you can tuck in your back pocket.
Starting with number seven, guarantee.
[music] Always remove the risk from the
person that you want to buy from you.
Number six, a killer offer. Make your
price or bundle so ridiculously generous
[music] that it would be stupid if they
didn't buy from you. Number five,
urgency and scarcity. Make sure that
there is a limitation in the stock, the
time, the spots available, or something
that they know if they don't get it
today, they may not be able to get it
tomorrow. Number four, big proof.
Testimonials, case studies, stories of
success. You have to let people know
that your product actually works. Number
three, the timeline of your promise. How
fast can you deliver results to your
people? The faster, the better, the more
you can charge. Number two, one of my
personal favorites, a unique promise.
What makes you different than everyone
else? Don't say better. It needs to be
simpler, easier, or faster. And the
number one thing that will help you
outsell everyone is an urgent problem.
What is the bleeding neck pain that if
they don't solve it today, they're going
to continue to have this [music] pain?
How do you solve it for them?